[Music]
Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I am going to teach you one
heck of an ambitious combo that I came
up with about a month ago and that went
super viral on Instagram before we dive
in I just want to give a quick shout out
to the Friends of the channel big thanks
to dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinski and
Becca beckonen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission so if you you haven't seen it
already this was an awesome video that I
did and posted to Instagram and that was
very very popular about a month ago and
I already did a video explaining the
process by which I wrote the
choreography for it what I haven't done
however is taken people through it step
by step this is a really really really
difficult piece of choreography not just
because it's moving very very rapidly
but also because there's a lot of
footwork involved therefore I wanted to
take some time and care and attention
with this one and show you all exactly
what goes into it if you're new here
please make sure to subscribe I produce
lots of videos around flow arts and POI
spinning I teach tutorials I teach
combos like this and yes I talk about
flow Arts culture as well so make sure
that you get the latest videos when they
come out all right so if you want to
learn this combo here's the list of
tricks that you're going to need it is
not a short one you're going to need to
know how to do cat versus pendulum
as well as how to do spiral wraps and
specifically spiral wraps in a
horizontal plane above your head
it's also going to be helpful to know
how to do meltdowns
as well as POI snakes but specifically
POI snakes that end in a hand switching
toss don't worry we'll go through the
details on how this works
you're also going to want to know how to
do you installs
and finally how to do Zan's diamond in
Split time opposites
so if you need to catch up and learn any
one of these tricks don't worry it's no
big deal I'm going to leave links to
tutorials for all these tricks down in
the description as well as up in the
cards if you happen to be watching this
video on YouTube first I'm going to show
you the combo of full speed then take
you through it step by step before
finally showing it to you again in slow
motion
[Music]
foreign
so real talk this one is a novel of a
combo it is designed to move back and
forth across the stage it is designed to
be fast it's designed to be exciting so
that's going to mean that there's going
to be a lot of changes happening
incredibly rapidly in here if you would
prefer it's not the worst idea in the
world to come at this from the
perspective of saying hey I'm going to
do a few more reps on all of these
things than Drex is because that will
probably make this more attainable to a
lot of people the tricks are really
Advanced the transitions are happening
incredibly quickly there is absolutely
no shame in taking this combo slower
than I am so with all that said let's
start to break this down I will say most
of the combo happens with me choking up
on my tethers just slightly normally I
do the kind of key grip that is typical
of tech POI Spinners this is one of
those cases where I'm actually gripping
from early from further up the tether
and having the tether like basically go
across the palm of my hand the reason
for this be being that it just makes the
POI more responsive to Quick stalls and
the like I find that that's very very
helpful with a lot of the stuff going on
here your mileage may vary but
especially when it comes to all the
stuff with the point isolations it may
be difficult to move your body around
fast enough to be able to you know move
across a full Poise length as those
Point isolations are happening if the
tethers are a little bit longer so this
combo to me is notable because it plays
around with contrast between two
different things the first is the
contrast between repetition versus
really rapid changes as well as things
like point isolations point isolations
pop up a lot in this combo and they're
used specifically to displace the body
rather than just displace the POI it
becomes a way to move the body around
which I personally think is really cool
so let's take a look at the first
instance of this the combo starts off
with me performing cap versus pendulum
here this this is a what I would
consider to be basically the uh the the
Gateway anti-bred this is probably the
first anti-brid you're going to learn if
you're going to learn them as I'm going
back and forth here I want you to pay
attention to either side of this trick
and note that there's always a moment to
my left as well as to my right when the
two POI form a straight line out to my
side it happens very very quickly but it
does exist the thing that first inspired
me to make this combo was actually
taking that moment and seeing if I could
execute a point isolation stall around
that straight line if you want you can
mess around with this a little bit and
practice boom doing that point isolation
stall and then coming back into pendulum
versus cap like part of the point of
this is to almost execute a magic trick
and see if you can rest the momentum of
the POI so quickly that the POI just
seemed to hang there in midair that's
the ideal here boom like so so we did
the point isolation stall and it was
lovely now we're gonna go to the second
part of this which is I'm gonna pull my
right hand around and do something that
I call the UFO this is just me doing
basically a two beats uh on a horizontal
plane as my right hand traces up and
down my left I want to show you
something very important about this look
at this from the side my right hand is
nowhere near my left hand I'm doing this
specifically because I would frequently
tangle this in earlier attempts at this
when I have them arranged in a straight
line like this the audience cannot tell
as far as they're concerned there's a
direct relationship between the two on
the side here though I'm making sure
that there's always several inches
between them to avoid those Tangles so
we're going to do once twice three times
with this as we're doing that I also
want to throw in a level change namely I
want you to plie with the right hand poi
every time that goes down now thing is
is that as you're doing this it's going
to be real tempting to bring down your
left hand with you because of course
your whole body is going down what I
want you to do is straighten out your
left hand every time you do the plie
like so I want you to try and isolate
that left hand POI in space and thus
have a contrast between the plie and
that POI just kind of sitting there
right now the third time you go down as
you come back up boom we're going to do
a little jump over to stage left I will
confess that in my head this is supposed
to be a butterfly kick I'm kind of
nervous about doing that with the mic
setup right here because I think I might
disconnect the mic but the theory is
that you're doing the jump right left go
up and you land over here at your right
hand side yeah or excuse me this is
stage left what am I talking about over
the stage left now this whole thing
flows together so as you're making that
leap boom you do a little horizontal
flower and as you come around you're
going to stop with a little horizontal
spiral wrap above your head as you're
doing that right hand comes around it
Taps the front of your body as that
spiral wrap completes and it also leads
the way back out now momentum really
truly is the key to this you're going to
take this moment and like almost make it
feel like a rebound as you push out to
do another horizontal flower as you turn
out to your right now as you're doing
this what leads it is that right hand
right foot excuse me rebounding off the
front of you it reaches out and that
kind of like you do a small plie first
and that takes you up for the turn the
turn you're going to Trail your left
foot behind you in what for me is the
sloppiest Arabesque ever but uh that is
the intention at least boom as you go
around it also has the effect of kind of
like uh tripping out that turn just a
little bit making it last a little bit
longer which I like
and this really is the momentum of this
keeps on traveling to Stage right so
after we do the come out boom as we come
around we find ourselves in the tail end
of a meltdown here kind of facing
downward to Stage right now what's
tricky about this is that we're only
doing half of the Meltdown I'm bringing
my right hand over in front of me and my
left hand behind me and then immediately
after I come out I'm switching over into
those snakes this is kind of a tough
reach you can think of it as being that
as you go around boom your right hand
continues it's uh it continues its
movement around back behind your back to
get to that position okay so coming out
of this position right here your right
hand is going to come around back behind
you your left hand is going to stay in
front you're going to keep the left hand
right where it is the right hand is
going to come around to meet it and that
is how you get into that snake very
crucial because my focus goes down to
Stage right in that meltdown I want my
focus to go out to stage left as I'm
doing the snake out to the side yeah all
right so this snake into a hand
switching throw this is something that I
would say that at this point I'm kind of
Infamous for here's how it works
normally when you're doing snakes out to
the side you're trying really hard to
place linear isolations around your
shoulders problem is is that the
placement of that doesn't work with
performing a stall along your Center
Line If you were to perform a stall
coming out of that it would wind up with
your hands crossed right so you have to
kind of fake it a little bit you have to
perform that linear isolation rather
than around your shoulders it's going to
happen instead around your elbows so
that when you pull in you have the right
alignment in order to hit that in order
to hit that stall which winds up looking
like this we go out we come in boom and
we switch now after I make the catch the
very first thing I'm going to do I'm not
even going to add any momentum to the
POI at all I'm going to take a you to
stall around back behind me yeah
um
there's one or two ways you can do this
you can do this either as an inside
pirouette or if you want to make the
combo finish in the same spot that it
started in you can do this as an outside
pirouette
either which way it works basically as
you take the pulley around here though
the momentum of them is going to get
them to stick out in space now when you
finish it over here to the side we're
going to execute one of my favorite
tricks which is basically taking that
moment when the two pointer out to the
side and turn that into the beginning of
Zan's Diamond the momentum of this is
really weird but I'll show you how to do
it so when you're doing Zan's diamond
and split time opposites there's this
point right here along the Middle where
you're having your hands in POI
switching positions vertically just
using linear extensions like this right
now the thing is is that when you're
doing linear extensions like this there
are places in there where the two POI
are just pointing out to either side the
trick is to use that's basically you're
almost treating it like it's a stall and
pulling the POI out of it so if you're
up top you're pulling your hand down and
treating it like a top stall if you're
on bottom you're treating it like it was
a bottom stall and you're pulling your
hand up right
so after we come out of our throw
we switch hands take it around now I'm
in a place where I've got my left hand
on top my right hand on bottom what I do
is I pull my left hand down my right
hand up boom and start into Zan's
Diamond I'm basically starting it along
the center line there you see that so my
right hand is going to come up my left
goes down they both go to the right then
left and boom I'm into Zan's Diamond I
will also say just as like a personal
choice here I really like taking the
entire body from side to side as we're
moving across yeah so I hope you do too
don't worry we're almost done we're
going to go through Zan's Diamond twice
and on the second time boom We stalled
both POI out to the right and we let
both of our hands swing down and
um I had to learn this the hard way that
you don't actually swing them all the
way to the left you kind of stop your
hands on Center Line and bring your
hands up a Poise width apart and as that
happens you can do a little Chasse over
to your left hand side and you drop into
to a static spin versus extension and
then back into a cap versus pendulum if
you want to start the combo over again
if not
wrap up the pull in your hands
and that's it cool let's take that from
the top so I have cap versus pendulum
which I boom to a point of iso stall out
I do some Plies jump and spiral up
Arabesque out to the side down into that
meltdown out into the snake toss take it
around I'm in Zan's Diamond once
I'm in Zan's Diamond twice boom take it
down and around switch around and
that's where I end it let's see that
again in slow-mo
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
wow so that's a heck of an elephant to
try and eat in one bite dear friends for
those of you who are going to try and
learn how to eat it anyway you have my
respect if I could also ask a quick
favor that is if you shoot video of
yourself doing this combo or maybe your
own version of it if there are some
parts that you want to change please if
you post that video online make sure to
tag me I'm drexfactor on both Instagram
as well as YouTube and I would love to
see your hard work
foreign
[Music]
to help other people find this video as
well as to help my channel grow this
video would not be possible without the
kind support of all of these awesome
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they along
with the people who sit down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your support
if you out there watching are not
currently a supporter and would like to
become one you can do so by heading on
over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get a bunch of awesome rewards such
as early access to my content as well as
a private lesson that gets delivered to
your personal inbox every single week
plus which you'll be helping me out in
my mission to bring POI spinning and
flowers to The Wider world and that will
make a lot of people happy so do go
check that out please and thank you all
right I'm officially melting here I need
to go back inside
um thank you all for watching if you
enjoyed this combo tutorial I have many
more like it I will uh include a link to
a playlist of those combos down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you're watching on YouTube in addition
the YouTube algorithm thinks that you
like this top video here so you might
want to give that a shot as well uh
thank you all so much for watching get
out and flow this weekend it's good for
your brain it's good for your body I
definitely know that I will and I will
see you all with a new video on Monday
peace